of course we're going to get political
here because a bunch of celebrities own
property on Maui and they're getting
roasted we have this one Tweet someone
said has Oprah opened up her stolen land
on Maui for displaced kanaka just
checking land back hey Oprah I know you
have 900 acres of land not far from the
fires in Lahaina are you planning on
opening your massive Farm to shelter the
locals and feed them I'm kindly waiting
for your response yeah I I don't I don't
I don't think they're going to open any
of their properties up to anybody dude
that was like native Island until when
did they when did the U.S conquer it
1940s yeah I think officially the 60s it
became U.S is it Jimmy Buffett who is
like either has a big property or like
owns part of an island in the Caribbean
there's some guy and I hope the chat
will know the story that like this
tropical destination he's deeply
involved in he lives there and uh this I
think it's I think it's Jimmy Buffett I
could be wrong uh he when when there was
a big earthquake on the island he opened
his home so people could stay there I
mean I think it really depends on how
tied to the community you feel